en 2017 jennifer tout juste arrivé à
marseille et loup en urgence en petit
studio situé dans le centre de la ville
elle ne se doute pas au premier coup
d'oeil qu'il s'agit d'un local à vélo
luis 520 euros par mois les odeurs dans
le logement dépourvu de système de
ventilation deviennent rapidement
nauséabonde et les moisissures
envahissent progressivement le petit
espace alors que jennifer demande à son
propriétaire d'agir elle découvre que ce
dernier est en adjoint au maire de la
ville face à son absence de réponse elle
décide de saisir la justice
moi j'avais vraiment envie que la
justice fasse son travail
pas forcément évident pas demandé de
dommages et intérêts aux choses
puisqu'elle après vous demande même pas
de de sam ou autres matchs jusqu en fait
c'est annuler mon bail si plus vraiment
que c'est un local à vélo quand j'ai
habité et moi j'ai vraiment essayé pour
un logement et noir local à vélo donc
quand je me suis présenté au procès
c'est vrai que j'étais très énervé
j'étais en quête de justice
aujourd'hui la jeune femme occupe
inconfortable studio et s'apprête en
avril prochain à revenir au tribunal
les héritiers du propriétaire décédé ont
fait appel en première instance il a été
condamné à lui rembourser tous les
loyers ainsi qu'à lui verser 2000 euros
de dommages et intérêts la famille blues
écrit mme vite elle aussi dans un
logement insalubre situé dans le
quartier populaire de noailles depuis
leur emménagement le propriétaire ne
veut pas rénové et ne vient pas
constater les problèmes de l'appartement
loué 550 euros par mois
la mairie a pourtant jugé le logement
insalubre ce qui autorise la famille à
ne plus payer le loyer quand que le
propriétaire n'a pas effectué les
travaux nécessaires mais celui ci n'a
toujours pas réagi faisant pas de
regarder pendant qu'elle connaît pas
d'après étape mois elles donnèrent la
première fois d'un agent pour
l'appartement mais c'est un savant selon
elle dans le jeu et les portes
aujourd'hui et vodafone au printemps
venez je n'ai pas de s'arranger l'effroi
pour le bébé pour un mois fin oui oui
oui
face aux nombreuses habitations
marseillaise insalubres le collectif du
5 novembre tente de faire bouger les
pouvoirs locaux
emmanuel patrice urbaniste de formation
est l'un des membres actifs de
l'association il dit
alors que la ville de marseille et la
métropole n'agissent pas et se renvoient
la balle au lieu de restaurer l'habitat
marseillais on a perdu deux ans et demi
depuis les effondrements de la rue
d'aubagne
en gros depuis cette annonce rien ou
presque s'est passé c'est un bilan
factuel catastrophique qu'on fait qu'on
fait aujourd'hui face à un sujet qui
clairement est problématique pour pour
les institutions parce que c'est un
chantier énorme a apporté quoi
selon le rapport nicole en 2015 il
existait 40000 taudis à marseille soit
cent mille personnes sur huit cent
soixante mille habitants qui vivaient
dans des logements insalubres
depuis l'effondrement rue d'aubagne le 5
novembre 2018
la mairie a procédé à cinq mille
évacuation mais 95 mille personnes sont
toujours concernés par l'insalubrité de
leurs logements
la ville de marseille et la métropole
n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer sur la
situation